ENJOY THE SUNSHINE.
♪.
BUSINESS OWNERS IN MIAMI BEACH
SAY SHERR SHOULDERING THE
ECONOMIC BURDEN OF THESE CURFEWS
AS BUSINESSES ON THE WEST COAST
SAY THEY’RE BEING PUNISHED
BECAUSE OF COVID RESTRICTIONS.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT BOTH THESE
CHALLENGES IS A OWNER OF THE
11th STREET DINER OF IN
MIAMI BEACH, AND OWNER OF A TIN
WHO ARE SALOON IN
BURBANK, CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING US.
>> THANK YOU.
MIKE: RAY, YOU HAD TO STAY IN
PLACE DURING PANDEMIC NOW ROWDY
SPRING BREAKERS IN MIAMI BEACH.
WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF ALL OF
THAT ON YOUR BUSINESS?
>> IT HAS BEEN TOUGH, NUMBER OF
ONE BACK IN JUNE, WE OPENED.
WE FOLLOWED ALL THE CDC
GUIDELINES, PROTOCOLS SO WE
COULD OPEN WHICH IS VERY COSTLY.
SO THAT WE COULD OPEN WITH
REGARD TO FOLLOWING THOSE
GUIDELINES.
NOW ONE WHICH WAS 50% INSIDE
DINING.
WHICH WAS OKAY.
WE COULD MAKE ENDS MEET WITH
INSIDE DINING WITH SIMPLY MEANT
OF OUTSIDE SEATING BUT AS TIME
PROGRESSED, THE WHOLE THING
ABOUT SPRING BREAK IT IS A
MISNOMER NUMBER ONE.
THE SPRING BREAK NOW, THIS HAS,
THIS STARTED WAY BACK WHEN,
YEARS AND YEARS AGO WHEN IT WAS
KIND OF BRANDED MEMORIAL WEEKEND
BRANDED AS URBAN WEEKEND.
SO THAT CARRY OVER CAME ALL THE
WAY INTO, INTO THE BEGINNING
WHEN DESANTIS LET US OPEN UP AT
THE END OF MAY, BEGINNING OF
JUNE.
WITH THE STIMULUS MONEY IN
PARTICULAR AND CHEAP AIR FLIGHTS
AND CHEAP HOTEL ROOMS, SLASH
AIRBNB, WE TO THE INFLUX OF
PREDOMINANTLY CITY PEOPLE.
MAJORITY ARE GREAT.
YOUNG KIDS, THEY PUSH THEM AS
FAR AS CAN BUT AS FAR AS THE
IMPACT NOW BECAUSE OF THE
CURFEW, WHAT SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED IN THE BEGINNING THE
CITY DROPPED THE BALL.
I WON’T GET INTO ALL OF THAT AS
FAR AS POLICING GOES BUT NOW,
THE MAYOR AND CITY OF MIAMI
BEACH WITH THE MANDATE FOR THIS
NEW CURFEW BECAUSE WE GOT
YO-YOKED ALL THE WAY FROM JUNE
UNTIL NOW INTO NOW A CURFEW FROM
8:00, 10, MIDNIGHT.
GOING BACK MIDNIGHT BACK TO
8:00, WE HAVE TO CLOSE AT 7:00.
IT TRULY IMPACTED OUR BUSINESS
AS FAR AS REVENUE GOES.
DURING THE DAY 60% OF OUR
REVENUES IS OUR MORNING SHIFT
AND 40% AT NIGHT.
WITHIN THAT 40% NOW WE HAVE BEEN
DOD DOWN TO 20% OF THAT 40%.
SO IT IS A, IT IS A BIG HIT BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, ON TOP OF
THAT, ONE OF THE GUESTS --
MIKE: LET ME WRAY IN OUR OTHER
GUEST.
BARRETT, YOU HAD CHALLENGES OF
YOUR OWN.
COVID AND GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
DECLARING RESTAURANTS CLOSED.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR STORY.
>> MIKE, YOU KNOW, WE’RE GOING
ALONG LAST YEAR, COMPLYING WITH
WHAT THEY WERE SAYING AND TOWARD
THE END OF LAST YEAR, ABOUT
DECEMBER, THEY JUST CLOSED
EVERYTHING BRAC DOWN AGAIN.
YOU KNOW, INDOORS, OUTDOORS.
NO EXPLANATIONS.
NO REASON.
IT JUST, AND THAT IS AFTER US
DOING ALL OF THE THINGS WE HAD
TO DO.
PLASTIC COVERINGS AND
EVERYTHING.
THEN AFTER THAT THREE OR
FOUR-DAYS, WITH NO REASON BEHIND
IT, I JUST OPENED UP, SIMPLY
OPENED UP.
I WAS GOING TO LOSE MY BUSINESS
ANYWAY.
THEY KEPT IT CLOSED DOWN FOR TWO
MONTHS, COMPLETELY CLOSED DOWN.
AND SO RIGHT NOW I’M RUNNING
WITHOUT POWER AND I’M RUNNING
WITHOUT PHONE LINES.
THE CITY HAS, THEY TRIED
PADLOCKING OUR DOORS WHICH YOU
KNOW, WE UNPADLOCKED THEM.
AND YOU KNOW, OUR SUPPORTERS
HAVE BEEN BEYOND TREMENDOUS AND
WE’RE WORKING.
WHERE WE ARE IN BUSINESS.
MIKE: BUT OBVIOUSLY QUITE
CHALLENGING WITH THE EXTRA
RESTRICTIONS, RIGHT?
>> REALLY DIFFICULT.
YOU KNOW.
MY SON AND MY DAUGHTER, REALLY
RUN THE DAY-TO-DAY OPERATIONS OF
IT.
AND, I -- YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE
HOW STRESSFUL IT IS.
WE HAVE BACKUP GENERATORS
SUPPORTERS HELPED US, HELPED
PROVIDED US THEY ACTUALLY DID
THE ELECTRICAL WORK AND
EVERYTHING.
TRYING TO RUN A RESTAURANT IS
COMPLICATED AND STRESSFUL ENOUGH
BUT WITHOUT POWER AND WITHOUT,
IT IS A MESS.
I CAN HONESTLY TELL YOU THAT.
MIKE: THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
WE WISH YOU AND YOUR EMPLOYEES
THE VERY BEST.